اهلا ومرحبا بكم في حواري فرنسا
وبعد مرور هذه المشاعر الغامره والصخب
الاعلامي حدثينا الان عن مشاعرك
والطباعاتك اليوم
مع الزمالك
الاخرين الذين عينوا من وكاله الفضاء
الاوروبيه التي تمثل الدول الاعضاء
الثانيه والعشرين وبعد وقع الاعلان نبدا
بالتصور اكثر باننا في المهنه صحيح ان هذا
الاعلان له وقع حقيقي هذا لا يحصل كل يوم
هل تسالنا لك كفايه بهذا الاختيار في
الواقع اللي كان هناك اثنان او ثلاث
استجوابات في الانتظار ولم تسمح لي الفرصه
للاحتفال بهذا الحدث انت متزوجه وام ما هو
رد افراد الاسره
اقربائي جدا راوني اعمل بطريقه شقه منذ
مده طويله لهذا الحدث
لهذا الحلم الذي يغمرني مده كانوا سعداء
جدا واسره موحده جدا وكل ما كان فرد سعيد
الكل يشعر بنفس السعاده هذه المهمه
والمهنه مهمه فيها تنقلات في محطه الفضاء
الدوليه انت معتاده نظرا لصلاه السابق كيف
ستدرين هذا الامر انا متفائله من حيث
طبيعتي وساديق الامور بطريقه جيده اليوم
لدينا وسائل الاتصال معروفه لدى الجميع
في فتره العزله كانت الاتصالات ناجحه جدا
انا مطمئنه كلها اللي اطمئنان بشان الحفاظ
على الاتصال باقاربه
الناس
يكتشفونك الان ومنذ البارحه هل يمكن ان
تحدثينا عن مسارك كل ما فعلتيه حتى تصبح
رائده لدى وكاله فضاء الاوروبيه ما فعلته
بطريقه ملموسه هو انني بدات بالدراسه في
مجال الهندسه كنت اود العمل في مسار علمي
بدات في سوبر
الاتصالات
المتنقله الدوليه وعاملته بعد ذلك في ام
بي سي هليكوبتر لانجاز تصميمي مقصوره
التيار وبعد ذلك اصبحت اشعر بشرفك
بمقصورات الهليكوبتر الى درجه انني ذكرتهم
محاوله مكتب في مكسوره بدل العمل بمكتبين
بشانها
وقدمت ترشيحي لجيش الجوي والفضاء لانه في
تلك الفتره كان هذا هو الكيان الوحيد الذي
يمكن من قياده الشئ 225
الهليكوبتر الذي كنت اعمل بشانه بصفه مهند
10 سنوات تقريبا كقائده عمليتها في الجيش
الجوي والفضائي هذه المهنه هي مهنه
استثنائيه تعملين كريد فضاء الكل يحلم
بذلك ولكن القليل من يصل الى هذا الحلم ما
الذي دفعك للمشاركه في هذه المسابقه
على وسيره تدريجيا وطويله جدا لم اصحى في
صباح وان اقول لنفسه ساصبح رائده فضاء بدا
ذلك بحلم طفله صغيره التي كانت مبهره وهي
تطلع على جمال النجوم بينما كنت على ركبت
جدي كان لديه علاقه وثيقه مع جدي كان يحكي
لي قصص عن التيارين والعلماء اشخاص
الهموني في الواقع وبعد ذلك كنت اقرا
كثيرا وخاصه السيره الذاتيه للاشخاص اول
سيره ذاتيه سياسيه
اخرى وهي انطلاق كلودين
كان عمري 14 سنه عندما ذهبت الى محطه مياه
وكان هذا بمثابه الزناد وقلت هذا هو
السبيل الذي تنهجه كان هذا هو حلمي تماما
انت الان ااه رايت الفضاء الثانيه بعد
كلودي ان يوغي تحدثي ايضا عن ماري كوري هل
كونك امراه يغير من الامر شيئا نعم ام لا
ان اكون امراه هذا جزء منها لا يمكنني ذلك
لكن بالنسبه لي هذه مهنه لا ترتكز على نوع
الجنس نرى ان هناك نساء رجال
ليس هناك نوع الجنس في هذه المهنه خلال
عمليه الانتقاء المقبله لرواد الفضاء لن
يتم هذا السؤال انا
العمل لا زال متواصلا حتى تتمكن المراه من
الالتحاق بهذا النوع المناصب في سكسي
مثاليه في هذا المجال شاهدنا انه من بين
الافراد 17 النهائيين الاحتياطيين او
الاخرين هناك تقريبا 50% من النساء نفس
الشيء بالنسبه للخمسه المنتقين هناك
ثلاثه رجال وكاله الفضاء الاولمبيات وقت
المثال في هذا الاتجاه ما الذي يجعلك
تحلمين في مهنتك المستقبليه كاراجه فضاء
فوتوشوب
مما يجلبني بالفعل اول شيء المغامره
الانسانيه الى جانب فرق الاوروبيه رائد
الفضاء يقضي وقت اطول على الارض بالمقارنه
مع الفضاء كل العمل يبدا مع الفرق
الاوروبيه الوكاله لها 22 بلد اوروبي
ويكون علينا ان نعمل مع علماء مساواه رفيع
من هذه البلدان الثاني والعشرين وبتابعه
الحال عندنا وكاله الفضاء الاوروبيه
المغامره الانسانيه لكن بعد ذلك عندما
نذهب على المحطه الفضائيه نعمل في بيئه
متعدده الثقافات وتشغيل لاجهزه المعقده في
بيئه معاديه لكننا بفضل تعاون دولي ايجاد
حلول لجعل هذه البيئه قابله للعيش وفي
نهايه المطاف المهمه هي الايثان في العلوم
والتكنولوجيا القيام بعمل البحث بالفعل
انا اشعر بجادبيه كبرى لكل هذا اريد ان
نتحدث عن هذه المسابقه وهذه الاختيار سنه
ونصف من الزمن اجراءات صعبه جدا كيف عشت
هذه الفتره
الكثير من السعاده
[موسيقى]
النفسي هو ان اكون سعيده في كل مرحله
ومهما كانت النتيجه
سلبيه بعد ذلك سعيده سعيده
كبيرا نعم
كبير عندما اكتشفت انه هناك اثنين
20,500 مرشح كنتم مصاحبه
معها اشخاص مع
الذي حضيته بلقائه في بدايه عمليه الفرز
والذي قال لي كوني واثقه بقدراتك ونفسك
وبيتالي لا تركزي على عدد
المرشحين الكبير عليك ان لا تفعل ذلك
[موسيقى]
في الفضاء وهي لا تذهب الى الفضاء بالفعل
علي ان اتعلم كل شيء وانطلق من الصفر سنه
لتدريب الاساسي في مركز الفضاء الاوروبي
موجود في كولونيا وهو مركز التدريب للرواد
الفضاء الاوروبيين ونحن ارواد الخامسه
الذين تم تعيينهم يوم امس سنكون هناك
ابتداء من ربيع المقبل تكليس سنه للتدريب
وبعد ذلك الذين
يلتحقون لمده سنتين لتدريب الخاص مما يعني
لانه هناك ثلاث سنوات تدريب كامله قبل
الامل في الذهاب الى الفضاء وبعد ذلك
القمر هو المريخ ربما سننتهي بالترتيب
الطبيعي سنبدا تعلم مهارات الاساسياء لهذا
الغرض يكون المدار الارضي المنخفض الاتجاه
المثالي نعم ان المحطه الدوليه وبعد ذلك
القمر هذا مخصص لرويد الذين لهم تجربه
وبالتالي علينا ان نتعلم قبل ذلك وبطبيعه
الحال هناك بعثات الخميس وكذلك وكاله
الفضاء الاوروبيه لها اماكن مخصصه للبعثات
للمقبله بالفعل ستكون هذه المرحله السحريه
لاستكشاف في
الفضاء والعوده الى
القمه
وكانت الفضاء الاوروبيه اعلنت عن ميزانيه
جديده تقدر بس 16.9 مليار يورو زياده في
هذه الميزانيه ما مدى اهميه هذه
الاستثمارات في وكاله الفضاء الاوربيه
بيعطي الحاله فهذا هي الزياده هي مهمه
فيما يتعلق ببعض التفاصيل فهناك المديريه
الاستكشافات البشريه والروبوتيه
فالامر يتعلق ب 35% من ميزانيه وهذا يؤكد
على اهميه البعثات في الفضاء لكن بصفه
عامه الفضاء موجود في حياتنا في هواتفنا
في الجي بي اس في الاتصالات والمواصلات
ومراقبه الارض وحل المشاكل المناخ الفضاء
موجوده في كل مكان في مواصلاتنا وفي
الانترنت وهذا مهم جدا بالفاعل من المهم
ان تكون فرنسا واوروبا اوروبا
على ال ميدان
التكنولوجيه تسمح لنا بان حلم المشاكل
المتعلقه بالمناخ ايضا سوف في النوم شكرا
جزيلا على هذا الحوار تهانينا الحاره كل
التوفيق في مهنتك المستقبليه شكرا شكرا
جزيلا بطبيعه الحال سنتابعك على فرانس 24
[موسيقى]